we got a chance to speak to dodger hall
of famer vin scully
yesterday after the show uh hunt
auctions is honoring uh the
great vince scully they're going to have
an auction and it's going to take place
coming up in september
and you're gonna you're gonna be able to
bid on some items here
his world series ring from 1988
you're also going to be able to bid on
the scorebook
in his last game that he did another
world series ring here uh president
reagan's
uh signed baseball to vin scully is also
in there
and i started out the conversation with
vince golly by asking him
how his summer was my summer
has been hide and seek the temperatures
out here
have been unusually high where our
backyard temperature one day
was 117. however
my wife and i spend most of our lives
now
at home so i could just sum up the
summer in two words
at home do you miss watching games or
calling games
you know i don't miss calling them at
all
and i must say i kind of demand
something
from the game i'm watching if it's a
very slowly played game
if it's just a long game i might just
turn it off
and go to bed we go to bed reasonably
early
so i like to watch him for a while
and right now it's for instance today
or this will be on the air tomorrow
friday but
today while we're taping this we have
football coming on tonight we have the
dodgers playing tonight we have a
basketball game tonight
so we spend our time my wife and i
bouncing from one sport to another
and on the weekend we really look
forward
to watching golf have you ever called a
game without
fans no never
maybe reasonably small crowds going back
to brooklyn
where you could hear the voices
of the individual fans i remember
i had just started with red barber and
connie desmond
and i was really a kid and there was a
famous woman fan her name was hilda
chester and she had a cowbell and she
worked away all over the ballpark she
was
extremely colorful and this particular
day
with a very small crowd i heard her
heavy voice say
then scully i love you
and the crowd whatever there was kind of
laugh and i lowered my head
and she said look at me when i'm talking
to you
that's how small the crowd was one day
in epistles
but how important is that crowd for you
especially when you're doing a game on
radio
oh i loved it i i've told this story
many times
when i grew up about eight years old we
had a big
four-legged radio and i would crawl
underneath it with some saltine crackers
and a glass of milk
and i would listen to a college football
game
and let's just say it was alabama
tennessee
i had no idea who was playing or
anything
but i learned to love the roar of the
crowd
and if i have a trademark or had it
would be
call to play as quickly and accurately
as i could
and then shut up and listen to the crowd
and for a few seconds i was eight years
old again
and someone during one of the world
series games
somebody hit a home run and i called the
home run
and as networks are one to do they
showed the home run again
and i just shut up and the columnist
wrote
perhaps vin scully made his greatest
contribution
by saying nothing and i really i took
that to heart
i didn't think of it as criticism i
thought of as yes you're right
the best thing i can do in the crowd
roars is shut up there's nothing better
but to have that self-discipline because
it feels like announcers want to
over call a game and here you are
having almost a seat belt on to say
plays over
quiet let the crowd or ambience settle
in
and it almost feels like it would draw
me closer
to the game while i'm listening because
i almost lean in more
because you're not saying anything yeah
i think
again it goes all the way back to my
love of the roar of the crowd probably
a couple of the longest pauses
while i had an enjoyment of listening to
the crowd
one would certainly be kirk gibson's
world series home run
and another one was henry aaron's
record-breaking home run
i mean what the heck can you say once
you've called the home run
except sit back and really luxuriate
listening to this crowd just be ecstatic
i loved it but you were also on the call
for the catch with joe
montana and dwight clark did you
react the same way in a football moment
as you would in a baseball moment
oh sure i mean if i remember there was
less than a minute to go
and montana throws to clark and the
catch is made
and the niners go out in front there was
still
some seconds left for dallas to come
back
but when dwight clark caught that i
believe
i said candlestick is a mad house
and i shut up and i just loved it i got
goosebumps and
that was the great part of the job
shutting up
he's uh vin scully the hall of famer the
former
dodger broadcaster and now on twitter
uh what took you so long to get on
twitter vin
well to be honest when i hung it up back
in
2016 i figured i had said
enough for a lifetime but after a while
i realized i didn't really miss doing
the game
but i kind of missed hearing from the
fans a little bit
and some friends of mine said you ought
to get on social media
and maybe you can exchange thoughts with
people
so after listening to some friends for a
couple of years
finally went on it and i don't plan to
do
anything controversial at no time
will i give an opinion i will only try
to deal in facts
and basically baseball facts nothing
else
so it'll be very low key and if
something is on twitter asking me a
question
if i can answer it i'd be more than
happy to do it and basically
that's why just for the fun of it i
guess you could say
vin is also auctioning off some of his
personal collection
and this will take place at september
23rd live
internet auction hunt auctions the
scully collection consists of materials
related to
his 67-year broadcasting career starting
with brooklyn and then the la dodgers
you're going back to the 50s up through
2016.
i think the last scorebook uh that you
had
scorecard is is in the auction give
people an idea what what is in the
auction and what made you come to this
decision to get rid of it you know when
one day i was looking at the collection
and it's pretty vast
and covers a lot of subjects and i
thought to myself
you know with the five children 16
grandchildren and three great
grandchildren
it would be better for me maybe
selfishly
to get money from the auction and give
it to the kids who have
a lot of little wants to educate as
opposed to
willing it to them and then i miss
seeing their joy
i'm gone from here so first of all i
guess it was selfish
that i wanted to share in whatever the
collection
would bring in on the auction as far
as the collection itself there's the
usual things
there's bats and balls and autographs
there's a japanese tea coat
which is really exceptionally rare that
was back in 1956
when the dodgers went to japan there are
several
letters from presidents along with
signed
presidential pictures which are kind of
rare
to give you an idea with the presidents
i had the pleasure
of playing golf with number 41 as they
call him
george herbert walker bush the late
president
and we had played golf together
and we also played against each other in
college
he was the first baseman at yale and i
tried to play center field
at fordham and that we played up at
new haven great game yale won it was
either two to one or three to one it was
a very good college game
and so when we were playing golf i said
to the president mr president
as long as you're in the white house you
can say anything you want
about your golf career or and also
your baseball career but i said remember
when you step out of the white house we
both went over three
well he just howled which is the kind of
man he was
and uh had a lot of fun doing that
so after our golf play about three days
later
a man showed up in the broadcasting
booth with a little box
and he said then whatever i said yes sir
he said a little gift from the president
wow i said thank you and i opened it up
and there was a little note that said
having seen you play
i think you could use a few more golf
balls
and in it were three presidential white
house balls
so there are some tongue-in-cheek
remarks from presidents
so they add a little something to the
usual collection
yeah i'm looking through you're giving
up world series rings
um i don't know i might have to open up
the wallet here vin i
i would love to have the score card from
your final game but i saw where the
estimate is between 10 and 15
000 i you know i don't have
any idea i don't really want to know
until it's all over
that way i won't be falsely elated
and i won't be depressed i will just
gratefully take
whatever they give me and immediately
turn it over
we're also contributing some money to
ucla
especially for neuromuscular
the so-called lou gehrig's disease
and hopefully that'll help it kind of
ties me in
with the disease in baseball and also
i i don't know what that must have felt
like when you see all of your
memorabilia
carted away was there one item where you
said your wife you know what maybe i
should keep that
no i never did that but i'll tell you
the one
stroke of i don't know
memorabilia attack was i was watching
them load
the truck because everything went back
to philadelphia
for safekeeping anyway they were loading
the truck and i was watching
calmly no emotion and all of a sudden
they brought out my golf clubs and when
they put those left-handed golf clubs
in the truck i realized that was a major
portion of my life
i could hear the door slamming and see
the
the clubs go off into the future i think
that was the biggest twins that i had of
all
did you play augusta no
i broadcast augusta what would happen is
the sunday the ball would roll into the
cup
the crew cbs crew would have a party
and they would play monday with the
sunday pin placements
meanwhile i was fighting traffic on a
sunday night
getting back to the airport to fly
wherever the dodgers were
to pick up on the play for monday so i
never
played augusta even though i ached to
play there
and a couple of times i was invited to
play
but it just didn't work with my schedule
so the answer
is a resounding no but i did play saint
andrews
which was certainly a close second
van i hope you're well sounds like
you're doing well and sorry about your
golf clubs but uh hopefully you're able
to
raise some money there and also a
portion will go benefit the uh
neuromuscular research at ucla thanks
again for joining us
dan my pleasure to be with you thanks
for the opportunity and
talk to you again one day that's the
dodger hall of famer and uh
the live internet auction september 23rd
that's hunt h-u-n-t hunt auctions
a 67-year broadcasting career of in
sculling